all of us remember what quadratic
polynomials are the general form of a
quadratic polynomial is ax squared plus
BX plus C where the constant a is not
equal to zero the degree of the
quadratic polynomial is - so what's the
quadratic equation an equation as we
know always has two sides one on each
side of the equal to sign when we equate
this general form of a quadratic
polynomial to zero we get the general or
standard form of a quadratic equation
remember that a is not equal to zero and
the constants a B and C are real numbers
for instance two x squared plus four X
plus two equals zero is a quadratic
equation comparing it to the standard
form we get a a to be as four and C as 2
a is the coefficient of x squared B is
the coefficient of x and C is the
constant this is called a quadratic
equation in variable X x squared plus 5x
plus 6 equals zero it's also a quadratic
equation negative 3x squared plus 12
equals 0 - yes you might not see the X
with power 1 in this equation but it
still is a quadratic equation that's
because the degree of the polynomial on
the Left if fill - can you find the
values of a B and C in each of these
cases
here are the values notice that in the
second case the value of coefficient of
x is zero and that's not a problem at
all
the important condition is that a must
not be equal to zero we can say that a
quadratic equation is of the form P of x
equals zero where P of X is a polynomial
of degree two does it have any
application in real life say you're
asked to build a rectangular football
field with an area equals to seven
thousand square meters and you're also
told that the length of the field should
be thirty meters more than its width how
would you build a field if this is the
rectangular field its area is seven
thousand square meters if its width is X
liters and based on the condition given
its length will be X plus 30 meters the
area of a rectangle is nothing but the
product of its length and breadth hence
X times X plus 30 will equal seven
thousand rewriting this will give us the
quadratic equation as x squared plus 30x
minus seven thousand equals zero and
this is nothing but a quadratic equation
but how will this give us the value of x
that's what we will learn in the coming
videos
[Music]